SEAN HANNITY LIVE FROM
NEW YORK CITY RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: TUCKER, GREAT SHOW.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
FOX NEWS ALERT TONIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT NOW TAKING MAJOR
ACTION TO SECURE OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
JUST MOMENTS AGO, ANNOUNCING A
BRAND-NEW TARIFF ON MEXICO,
PRESSING THIS COUNTRY NOW TO
STEM THE FLOW OF MIGRANTS THAT
ARE OVERWHELMING OUR ENTIRE
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
WE WILL HAVE A LOT MORE LATER IN
THE PROGRAM.
FIRST THOUGH TONIGHT, THE
DEEP STATE IS IN A COMPETE
, A COMPLETE PANIC MODE.
THE WALLS ARE CLOSING IN.
DAYS AWAY AS WE BEEN TOLD ON THE
RELEASE OF MAJOR DOCUMENTS
EXPOSING
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL SAYS HE
EXPECTS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
HOROWITZ TO REPORT ON FISA ABUSE
ANY DAY.
WE ALSO HAVE THE OTHER BUCKETS,
EXPOSING WHAT'S THE REAL
ELECTION SCANDAL, ONE TO ROBIN
ELECTION AND SECONDLY UNDERMINE
A DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT.
BUT FIRST, AS WE TOLD YOU LAST
NIGHT, THE RUSSIA HOAX?
IT'S DAD.
IT'S BURIED.
IT'S NONEXISTENT.
BY THE WAY, NINE HOURS AFTER HIS
NINE AND A HALF MINUTE STATEMENT
FUELING DEMOCRATS' HOPES AGAIN
AND MORE HYSTERIA AND BREATHLESS
REPORTING, ROBERT MUELLER HAS A
READY BACKTRACK.
LAST NIGHT, THEIR DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND THE SPECIAL COUNSEL,
THEY ACTUALLY HAD TO RELEASE A
JOINT STATEMENT TO CORRECT WHAT
MUELLER SAID.
IN OTHER WORDS, MUELLER NEEDED
TO WALK BACK EVERYTHING HE SAID
YESTERDAY IN A DRAMATIC FASHION
BECAUSE HE TOTALLY CONTRADICTED
EVERYTHING THAT HE HAD BEEN
SAYING.
CLARIFICATION, WELL, IT WASN'T
EXACTLY THAT.
BUT SAID THIS.
FOR THE OLC, OFFICE OF LEGAL
COUNSEL'S OPINION, THAT MUELLER
WOULD HAVE FOUND THE PRESIDENT
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE.
MUELLER'S STATEMENT ENTIRELY
CONSISTENT WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S PREVIOUS
REMARKS IN SPITE OF THE MEDIA
MOB'S COVERAGE.
REMEMBER, BARR SAID THAT ROBERT
MUELLER TOLD HIM OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AND NUMEROUS OTHER PEOPLE
HEARD IT AND EXPLAINING JUST
WEEKS AGO, MUELLER STATED THREE
TIMES TO US IN THAT MEETING THAT
HE EMPHATICALLY WAS NOT SAYING
THAT BUT FOR THE OFFICE OF LEGAL
COUNSEL'S OPINION, HE WOULD'VE
FOUND OBSTRUCTION.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT POLICY OF WHETHER YOU
CAN OR CANNOT INDICT A SITTING
PRESIDENT, WAS NEVER AN ISSUE,
PERIOD.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN?
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR SAID
TODAY THAT MUELLER COULD'VE
REACHED A CONCLUSION AS TO
WHETHER THERE WAS ANY CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY, BUT HE CHOSE NOT TO.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I PERSONALLY FELT HE COULD'VE
REACHED A DECISION.
>> IN YOUR VIEW HE COULD'VE
>> HE COULD'VE REACHED A
CONCLUSION.
TO INDICT A PRESIDENT WHILE HE
IS IN OFFICE BUT HE COULDN'T
REACH A DECISION AS TO WHETHER
IT WAS CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
HE HAD HIS REASONS FOR NOT DOING
IT, WHICH HE EXPLAINED.
I'M NOT GOING TO, YOU KNOW,
ARGUE ABOUT THOSE REASONS.
BUT WHEN HE DIDN'T MAKE A
DECISION, THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD ROSENSTEIN
AND I FELT IT WAS NECESSARY FOR
US AS THE HEADS OF THE
DEPARTMENT TO REACH THAT
DECISION.
>> Sean: 'S OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, BY THE WAY,
THAT'S BECAUSE DEMOCRATS WANTED
TO GET RID OF THE OLD IN THE
MENDING CONSOLE STATUTE.
THAT MEANS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
IS THE FINAL ARBITER.
HE MADE UP HIS MIND.
ALONG WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
ROD ROSENSTEIN AND THE
NONPARTISAN OFFICE OF LEGAL
COUNSEL.
THEY WERE ALL CRYSTAL-CLEAR.
THE MEDIA MOB -- LET ME SPELL IT
OUT FOR YOU.
ZERO FINDINGS THAT THE PRESIDENT
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE.
NONE.
BY THE WAY, IT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH SOME JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
POLICY.
NOT BECAUSE OF A LEGAL,
CONSTITUTIONAL RESTRICTION, BUT
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE.
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
THIS IS NO COVER-UP, NO CASE
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT, NO
COLLUSION, NO UNDERLYING CLIMB
DOWN THE CRIME, THE OBSTRUCTION.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE OPPOSITE OF
HILLARY.
BUT FOR THE EXTREME SOCIALIST
DEMOCRATS, THE RAGE TRUMPED
MEDIA MOB, THOUGH THEY REFUSED
TO FOCUS IN ON THE MAJOR TRUTH
OF THIS ISSUE.
ASK YOURSELF THIS, WHY DIDN'T
THE MEDIA MOB REPORT WITH THE
SAME INTENSITY, THE RELEASE OF
THE CLARIFYING REMARKS OF ROBERT
MUELLER AFTER HE BOTCHED IT
YESTERDAY MORNING?
WHY DIDN'T THEY PUT THE SAME
PASSION IN IT AS THE NIGHT AND A
HALF MINUTES OF ROBERT MUELLER?
HERE'S ANOTHER QUESTION.
WHY ARE THEY SO LAZY, SO
PREDICABLE, SO PARTISAN, WHY ARE
THEY FAKE NEWS?
WHY DO THEY FEIGN MORAL OUTRAGE
AND THEN PURPOSELY FAIL TO TELL
THEIR VIEWERS, AS LITTLE AS THEY
ARE, THE TRUTH?
HOW DID IT BECOME SO PARTISAN,
SO POLITICAL, SO CORRUPT, THAT
THEY REFUSE SIMPLE QUESTIONS AND
INFORM THEIR VIEWERS.
THAT CLARIFICATION OF MUELLER
WAS MASSIVE.
THE CORRECTION WAS MASSIVE.
SO WHY DO THEY CHOOSE TO
CONTINUE TO PADDLE ANOTHER ROUND
OF LIVES AND CONSPIRACY THEORIES
AND ADVANCE THEIR HOAX YET
AGAIN.
WHY DID THEY CHOOSE TO ACT AS
PARTAKEN HICKS INSTEAD OF
SERIOUS JOURNALISTS?
BY THE WAY, 98.9% OF MEDIA GOT
IT WRONG.
IT'S THE TALK SHOW HOSTS, WE DO
STRAIGHT NEWS, WE DO OPINION,
BUT WE ARE HONEST ABOUT IT, AND
EVEN SPORTS AND CULTURE.
THEY SAY THEY ARE OBJECTIVE.
THEY ARE ANYTHING BUT.
BUT WHY ARE THEY CHOOSING TO PUT
FAKE NEWS NARRATIVES OVER THE
FACTS THAT AFTER TWO PLUS YEARS
OF LYING AND CHOOSING TO
RELENTLESSLY SMEAR, SLANDER,
BESMIRCH ANYBODY WHO DARES TO
QUESTION THEIR LACK OF ETHICS
AND NOT OBJECTIVITY.
LOOK AT THIS TONIGHT.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES"?
THEY ARE NOW SCARED, TAKING
NOTICE, AND THEY ARE REALIZING,
OH, THEY'VE BEEN DUPED BY THE
CONSPIRACY TV MEDIA MOB.
LOOK AT THIS NEW REPORT.
"NEW YORK TIMES" IS WARNING
EDITORS AND REPORTERS AGAINST
APPEARING ON PRIME TIME SHOWS ON
THE FAKE SNOOZE SEE AND THEN AND
CONSPIRACY TV MSNBC.
WHY WOULD THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
NOT GO ON THEIR FAVORITE
PROGRAMS?
WE  WHO REFUSED TO ASK TOUGH
QUESTIONS TO BEGIN WITH IT LIKE,
DID ROBERT MUELLER FORGET HIS
PREVIOUS STATEMENTS IN
YESTERDAY'S REMARKS, OR DID HE
INTENTIONALLY MUDDIED THE WATERS
TO FUEL THE DEMOCRATS'
UNRELENTING IMPEACHMENT RAGE
PSYCHOSIS?
NOW THE PRESIDENT IS STANDING
STRONG, NOT LETTING HIMSELF BE A
PUNCHING BAG, TAKING DIRECT AIM
AT THE FORMER SPECIAL COUNSEL AS
HE SHOULD, AND HIS PARTISAN
WITCH HUNT.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> ROBERT MUELLER SHOULD'VE
NEVER BEEN CHOSEN.
BECAUSE HE WANTED THE FBI'S JOB
AND HE DIDN'T GET IT AND THE
NEXT DAY HE WAS PICKED AS
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
SO YOU TELL SOMEBODY, I'M SORRY,
YOU CAN'T HAVE THE JOB.
AND THEN YOU AFTER SAY THAT,
HE'S GOING TO MAKE A RULING ON
YOU?
IT DOESN'T WORK THAT WAY.
I THINK MUELLER IS A TRUE AND
NEVER TRUMPER, SOMEBODY WHO
DISLIKES DONALD TRUMP.
AND DESPITE $40 MILLION, 18
TRUMP HATERS, INCLUDING PEOPLE
WHO WORK FOR HILLARY CLINTON AND
SOME OF THE WORST HUMAN BEINGS
ON EARTH, THEY GOT NOTHING.
IT'S PRETTY AMAZING.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT, HE
DIDN'T STOP THERE.
CALLING OUT THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
MORE THAN A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST, WRITING "ROBERT
MUELLER CAME TO THE OVAL OFFICE
TO BE CLAIMED DIRECTOR OF THE
FBI.
HE WAS ALREADY IN THAT POSITION
FOR 12 YEARS, I TOLD HIM NO
BACK.
NEXT DAY, HE WAS NAMED SPECIAL
COUNSEL, TOTAL CONFLICT OF
INTEREST."
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT.
HERE'S THE BIG TAKE AWAY OF ALL
OF THIS.
ROBERT MUELLER, I'M TELLING YOU.
SCARED TO DEATH TO TESTIFY.
WHY CLICK MAKE YOU HAVE TO
ANSWER REAL TOUGH QUESTIONS FROM
ANSWER REAL TOUGH QUESTIONS FROP
ANSWER REAL TOUGH QUESTIONS FROO
ANSWER REAL TOUGH QUESTIONS FROI
ANSWER REAL TOUGH QUESTIONS FROE
ANSWER REAL TOUGH QUESTIONS FROC
ANSWER REAL TOUGH QUESTIONS FRON
ANSWER REAL TOUGH QUESTIONS FROR
ANSWER REAL TOUGH QUESTIONS FROS
ANSWER REAL TOUGH QUESTIONS FROM
ANSWER REAL TOUGH QUESTIONS FRON
ANSWER REAL TOUGH QUESTIONS FROJ
ANSWER REAL TOUGH QUESTIONS FROM
ANSWER REAL TOUGH QUESTIONS FROR
ANSWER REAL TOUGH QUESTIONS FROA
ANSWER REAL TOUGH QUESTIONS FRO,
CONGRESSMAN MARK MEADOWS,
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES, AND
OTHERS.
BY THE WAY, DEVIN NUNES WILL BE
HERE IN JUST MOMENTS.
HE WOULD BE AFRAID TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS LIKE THIS TO MUELLER.
"WHEN DID YOU KNOW THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION?"
BY THE WAY, IF YOU HAD ALL THIS
TIME TO INVESTIGATE, TAXI
MEDALLIONS, LOAN APPLICATIONS,
DECK
DECADES OLD TAXING RETURNS, HOW
DID YOU HAVE NO TIME TO
INVESTIGATE THE ORIGINS OF
HILLARY CLINTON'S DIRTY RUSSIAN
DOS HERE WHICH WAS USED TO
COMMIT A PREMEDITATED FRAUD ON
THE PFIZER COURT, UNDERMINE A
DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT AFTER
AN ATTEMPT TO STEAL AN ELECTION
ELECTION.
ALSO TO DISSEMINATE RUSSIAN LIES
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND SPY
ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, WHICH AS
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTED,
THAT DOSSIER WAS LIKELY RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
MR. MUELLER, WHY DID YOU HIRE A
TEAM OF PARTISAN DEMOCRATS, NOT
A SINGLE REPUBLICAN -- YOU
COULDN'T FIND ONE?
NO ONE?
WHY WOULD YOU EVER HIRE A GUY,
YOUR PIT BULL, BY THE NAME OF
ANDREW WEISSMANN, A GUY WHO HAS
A HORRIFIC HISTORY OF ABUSE OF
POWER.
REMEMBER COMMIT IN THE POWELLS
BOOK, "LICENSE TO LIE,"
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE.
WAS AT THE HILLARY CLINTON
ELECTION NIGHT, THE PARTY THAT
NEVER HAPPENED.
WHY WOULD YOU HIRE THE
HILLARY CLINTON JEANNIE
HOW COULD HE IN GOOD FAITH
IGNORE THE SINGLE BIGGEST ABUSE
OF POWER, CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN
MODERN POLITICAL HISTORY WHICH,
BY THE WAY, HAD TO DO WITH THE
RUSSIAN LIES AND THEIR ATTEMPT
TO STEAL AN ELECTION IN 2016?
JUDICIAL WATCH'S TOM FITTON,
FIGHTING BACK IN A HUGE WAY.
TONIGHT, HE IS CALLING FOR
ACTION ON MUELLER'S ATTACK ON
THE RULE OF LAW FOR TURNING IT
ON ITS HEAD AND ABANDONING
LONG-HELD PRICING RHETORICAL
NORMS.
BY THE WAY, DON'T FORGET, ABOUT
HIS COZY RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
SUPER PATRIOT JAMES COMEY.
NOTHING LIKE SMELLY WALNUT
THEY HATE TRUMP DEMOCRATS, THEY
STILL DON'T CARE.
THEY RELY ON THE SAME
DISPARAGEMENT THAT HAPPENS EVERY
SINGLE SECOND OF EVERY SINGLE
MINUTE OF EVERY SINGLE HOUR OF
EVERY SINGLE DAY FOR THEY ARE ON
A MISSION, THEY WANT TO TAKE
DOWN THE PRESIDENT AT ALL COST
PER DOESN'T MATTER HOW GREAT OF
A JOB HE'S DOING.
IT WOULDN'T MATTER IF HE CURED
CANCER.
EVERY SINGLE WAKING MOMENT A
PUBLIC TRIAL AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS NOT ONLY BEEN
SUCCESSFUL, BUT UNDER THE WORST
CONDITIONS THAT ANY PRESIDENT
HAS HAD TO START THE PRESIDENCY
UNDER, REGARDLESS OF FACTS,
TRUTH, REALITY.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE NO AGENDA TO
MAKE US MORE SAFE, MORE
PROSPEROUS, MORE SECURE.
AS ANY DEMOCRAT TALKED ABOUT
THAT RECENTLY?
NO PLAN FOR AMERICA'S FUTURE,
OUR KIDS, OUR GRANDKIDS, NO PLAN
TO GROW THE ECONOMY, MAKE JOBS,
MAKE US ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
NO PLANS TO SOLVE THE CRISIS AT
OUR BORDER.
NO PLANS TO MAKE A STRONGER
ABROAD.
AND YOU'VE GOT THIS PATHETICALLY
WEAK FIELD OF 2020 RADICALS.
THEY SPEND THEIR TIME AND
COHERENTLY RAMBLING ABOUT HOW
MUCH THEY HATE THE PRESIDENT AND
THE NEW GREEN DEAL WHICH WILL EI
THE NEW GREEN DEAL WHICH WILL EA
THE NEW GREEN DEAL WHICH WILL EE
THE NEW GREEN DEAL WHICH WILL ET
THE NEW GREEN DEAL WHICH WILL EC
THE NEW GREEN DEAL WHICH WILL EM
THE NEW GREEN DEAL WHICH WILL EU
THE NEW GREEN DEAL WHICH WILL ET
THE NEW GREEN DEAL WHICH WILL EO
THE NEW GREEN DEAL WHICH WILL EN
ENGINE, OIL AND GAS, COWS AND
AIRPLANES.
CAN'T WAIT.
EVERYTHING ELSE WILL BE FREE.
THE COLLUSION HOAX IS DEAD AND
FINISHED, IN SPITE OF ALL THE
NOISE YOU HEAR, IT'S DONE.
FOUR IN SEPARATE INVESTIGATIONS,
FOUR, AND ALL OF THEM FOUND --
FDR NINE MONTH INVESTIGATION,
HOUSE INTEL INVESTIGATION,
BIPARTISAN SENATE INVESTIGATION,
AND THE MUELLER REPORT, FOUR
OF THEM, NO CONSPIRACY
COLLUSION.
AND WE NOW KNOW FROM
MR. MUELLER'S RETRACTION,